hi my name is Paula and I am a software
engineer at Microsoft let's talk about
how the internet works my job relies on
networks being able to talk with one
another but back in the 1970s there was
no standard method for this it took the
work of Vint Cerf and Bob Kahn
to invent the internet working protocol
to make communication possible this
invention laid the groundwork for what
we now call the Internet the Internet is
a network of networks it links billions
of devices together all around the globe
so maybe you're connected with a laptop
or a phone through Wi-Fi
but then that Wi-Fi connection connects
to an Internet service provider or ISP
and that is P connects you to billions
and billions of devices around the world
through hundreds of thousands of
networks that are all interconnected one
thing that most people do not appreciate
is that the Internet is really a design
philosophy and an architecture expressed
in a set of protocols a protocol is a
well-known set of rules and standards
that if all parties agree to use it will
allow them to communicate without
trouble how the internet actually
physically works is less important than
the fact that this design philosophy has
allowed the internet to adapt and absorb
new communication technologies this is
because in order for a new technology to
use the Internet in some fashion it just
needs to know which protocols to work
with all the different devices on the
Internet have unique addresses an
address on the Internet is just a number
similar to a phone number or a sort of
street address that's unique to each
computer or device at the edge of the
network this is similar to how most
homes and businesses have a mailing
address you don't need to know a person
to send them a letter in the mail but
you do need to know their address and
how to write the address properly so the
letter can be carried by the mail system
to its destination the addressing system
for computers on the Internet is similar
and it forms part of one of the most
important protocols
used in Internet communication simply
called the Internet Protocol or IP a
computer's address then is called its IP
address visiting a website is really
just your computer asking another
computer for information your computer
sends a message to the other computer's
IP address and it also sends along its
origin address so the other computer
knows where to send its response you may
have seen an IP address it's just a
bunch of numbers these numbers are
organized in a hierarchy just like a
home address has a country a city a
street and a house number and IP address
has many parts just like all digital
data each of these numbers is
represented in bits traditional IP
addresses are 32 bits long with 8 bits
for each part of the address the earlier
numbers usually identify the country and
regional network of the device then come
the sub networks and then finally the
address of the specific device this
version of IP addressing is called ipv4
it was designed in 1973 and widely
adopted in the early 80s and provides
for more than 4 billion unique addresses
for devices connecting to the internet
but the Internet has turned out to be
much more popular than even Vince Cerf
imagined and four billion unique
addresses won't be enough we're now in
the middle of a multi-year transition to
a longer IP address for me called ipv6
which uses 128 bits per address and
provides over 340 undecillion unique
addresses that's more than enough for
every grain of sand on earth to have its
own IP address most users never see or
care about internet addresses a system
called the domain name system or DNS
associates names like WWE example.com
with the corresponding addresses your
computer uses the DNS to look up domain
names and get the Associated IP address
which is used to connect your computer
to the destination
on the internet like this hey hi there I
want to go to WWE
mm yeah I don't know the IP address for
that domain let me ask around
hey I know I get to uh code.org know
that while you it's all 1:7 4.1 to 9.14
da-jung to zulan oh okay great thanks
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna write that down
and save it for later in case I mean hey
here's that address you wanted awesome
thank you
so how do we design a system for
billions of devices to find any one of
billions of different websites there is
no way one DNS server can handle all the
requests from all devices the answer is
the VMS servers are connected in a
distributed hierarchy and are divided
into zones splitting up responsibility
for the major domains such as dot or
ComNet etc VMs was originally created to
be an open and public communication
protocol for government and educational
institutions because of its openness VMs
is acceptable to cyberattacks an example
attack is DNS spoofing that's when a
hacker taps into a DNS server and
changes it to match a domain name with
the wrong IP address this lets the
attacker send people to one is poster
website if this happens to you you are
vulnerable for more problems because you
are using that fake website as if it is
real the Internet is huge and getting
bigger every day but the domain name
system and Internet Protocol are
designed to scale no matter how much the
internet grows
you